now moving on to other news and Human
Rights Watch is accusing Egypt of
arresting and torturing children as
young as 12 years old a report from the
International rights group says abuses
by security forces took place against at
least 20 children with the majority
being tortured in pretrial detention HRW
says the criminal justice system under
President Abdel Fattah el-sisi has
failed to seriously investigate the
children's allegations of torture well
for more on this let's speak to Aamir
mug mug D he is a Middle East and North
Africa researcher at Human Rights Watch
and he joins us now on skype from Berlin
I'm reading through this report I mean
some of the descriptions by the children
of their experiences are utterly
horrific waterboarding being
electrocuted talk us through what you
found thank you and for giving me this
time I think this report she sheds the
light again on how the machinery of
repression and torture in Egypt is
working and how this machinery has also
affected children we are talking about
20 cases we documented in this report
that are just a small sample
representative of the systemic nature of
such practices of disappearances and
torture by the security agencies in
Egypt particularly the National Security
Agency under the Interior Ministry those
children are usually rounded up during
let's say unrest or political upheaval
or mass protests so for example the
recent the most recent of which was the
September and October mass protests in
Egypt even during that time also we
witnessed definitely mass arrests and
maybe 200 children we're arrested I
think the title of the report summarizes
the situation or what happens exactly no
one cared he was a child so when these
children are arrested they are not
really looked at as
rather they are looked at as criminals
as political opponents in that sense and
they are disappeared they are tortured
by beating by electrocution
waterboarding hanging in stress
positions extremely painful stress
position positions to obtain information
and also to punish them for whatever
perceived political activity or
affiliation and later they are sent to
persecutors who charge them with
serious charges and many of those
children stood trial before terrorism
courts and even military trials as well
military courts about the systemic
nature of this you are saying that the
torture itself sounds like it's systemic
and the lack of action that's being
taken against the security forces were
perpetrating the abuse the actual
torture does that suggest that the
torture itself is state sanctioned we
believe so in human rights watch this is
not the first three point about torture
in Egypt torture has been heavily
reported by media outlets by human
rights organizations and even by the UN
Committee Against Torture and the
special report or against torturing the
UN who are also powered from visiting
the country because Egypt does not want
to cooperate with these international
mechanisms and doesn't want to open its
detention centers for independent
inspections and visits and therefore
this is kind of a green light from the
political leadership for the officers to
go on with their abuses to go on with
this abusive extremely abusive behavior
very very few officers in Egypt's
history have been found guilty with
torture charges the Egyptian law itself
not really properly defined torture and
does not define our human eyes enforced
disappearance as it should according to
international standards and
unfortunately even though the egyptian
child law of 1996 which was a regular
slate amended in between 2008 that
actually enshrines a lot of guarantees
for how to deal with children and the
judicial system however there's a very
serious loophole that the Egyptian
Authority has utilized and relied on
heavily to persecute children which
allow for the persecution of children
before criminal courts when there is
even just one adult account with
syndication I'm I'm like those we're
going to leave it there I'm afraid
that's my mug dear researcher at Human
Rights Watch thank you for joining us on
al Jazeera